in this video I'm going to show you how
to set up the right python environment
for you so a lot of people coming from
like an R background who are switching
to python they're very familiar with
something like R studio and then it's
common to ask well what IDE do I use for
python well I'm going to show you
exactly what I use and what I recommend
depending on what you're trying to do
and what your experience level with
python is so if that sounds good to you
tap the like button to this video
subscribe subribe to my YouTube channel
if you haven't already then let's get
started so if you're somebody who's
brand new to python maybe you want to
just get started doing a quick ad hoc
analysis maybe you just want to learn a
little bit of basic functionality and
you're sort of intimidated by setting up
a development environment I would really
recommend getting started with
Anaconda the reason for that is this is
going to be the absolute simplest least
overhead way to get started writing
python code so you're going to go over
here to anaconda.com
download and you're going to see this
download link down here now I'm using a
Windows for this but there are
additional installers for Mac or for
Linux you're going to click download and
it's going to kick off uh downloading
the installer once we get that installer
downloaded and opened up we're just
going to move through it install just
for you pick a destination folder the
one thing I would change here is I would
add Anaconda 3 to your path environment
variable that is going to make things
easier for you later we're going to go
ahead and click install and now this
process takes a little bit of time so
we're going to come back when we're done
now once you've got Anaconda Navigator
open scroll down here to Jupiter lab and
let's launch that now Anaconda is a full
platform with a ton of applications on
it and for what we're doing here either
Jupiter lab or Jupiter notebook will
work I personally prefer the layout that
you get in Jupiter lab but either one
will work once that launches go under
here to Python 3 under the notebook and
we're ready to write python code I'm
going to start with a simple hello world
statement look at that it works so we
could check our python version to do
that you're going to do exclamation
point python D-
version and we find that we're running
Python
3.1.5 and notice I did not install
anything else on my machine other than
Anaconda Navigator and already all this
stuff is good to go so you can run this
command pip
freeze and this is going to show you all
the packages that you have in your
environment so you'll see a lot of
really basic core fundamentals that a
lot of people use for Python Programming
all this stuff is already set up it's
good to go you don't have to do anything
with it so if we want to just confirm
that just do import pandas SPD do
that and we're ready to go with any kind
of functionality from pandas so for a
lot of people working in Anaconda using
Jupiter lab and Jupiter notebooks that
might be all that you need so I
personally use notebooks all the time if
I'm working on like a complicated script
that somebody else wrote I need to
understand what it's doing how the data
is changing as it's going through a
pipeline of functionality sometimes I'll
just copy the code into here break it
down into little chunks run some head
statements and just see what's going on
with the data then then you can even
share that with somebody else that may
be all that you need but there's
definitely going to be some limitations
in the things that you're able to do do
using strictly uh Jupiter so that's
where you want to have a good text
editor where you can run Python scripts
locally um that's where I would
recommend Visual Studio code so there's
a ton of different python text editors
out there there's pycharm there's emac
there's Vim Visual Studio code is my
personal favorite and the one that I
would recommend using so we're going to
go to download up here and get started
next I'm going to show you how to get
started in Visual Studio code and how to
set up a virtual environment before we
do that though there is one important
step where if you don't do this you're
very likely to run into an error so you
want to go to Windows Powershell and you
want to run as an
administrator so it may give you a popup
window get your terminal over here and
we're going to run the command
set- execution policy remote
signed again if we don't do this it's
going to try and activate a virtual
environment later using Powershell and
if we don't do this it's not going to
work so you want to run either y or a
and then we're good to go now we're
ready to get started with Visual Studio
code or vs code so the first thing I
want to draw your attention to is this
tab on the side that looks like a bunch
of Windows this is the extensions Tab
and the first thing you're going to have
to do is install the python extension so
you should see an install uh button over
here if you don't have it already get
that set up now Visual Studio code
offers us plenty of different extensions
that we can use many of which make our
programming experience a lot easier so
in particular a couple that I recommend
uh black is a really good
one right here this one is really good
for formatting and for styling so we
could install that one another one that
I really recommend is flake
8 so this one is really good for uh for
linting so this one will provide a
number of recommendations like you have
lines which are going over 79 characters
maybe you should wrap them in multiple
lines instead of one long line so it
makes the code uh good style and easy to
read now let's take vs code for a spin
we're going to go up to new file and if
you installed that python extension
earlier you should see an option here
for a python
file so we're going to give this a name
just call it
test and let's make it super basic it's
just also going to be a basic hello
world
statement we're going to go up here and
we're going to run
that so The Interpreter that I'm using
right now actually came directly from
that Anaconda installation if you look
down here in the corner it's python
3.1.5 with
bonda again that comes directly from
that installation that I did earlier
from Anaconda so that's in my
environment variables VSS code is able
to find that obviously you're more than
welcome and able to to use different
versions of python uh download install
those and use different interpreters and
versions of python but either way uh
this successfully executed we return to
hello world down here so VSS code is
going to be a great environment for you
to work in to run and maintain scripts
very easily style your scripts to make
them look nicer and just collaborate
with developers easier and push things
and pull things from GitHub but as you
start working on multiple projects
you're going to want to start setting up
what's known as virtual environments now
this is going to be the last topic for
this tutorial and a virtual environment
sounds like something super
sophisticated but it's actually a really
simple concept the whole idea is you
might work on different projects with
completely different sets of
dependencies so just making an example
up here one project may require Panda's
version
1.2.5 and another project requires
pandas
1.8.3 just as an example and so once you
start changing your environment around
to accommodate pandas
1.8.3 other stuff is going to start
breaking and not working so really what
a virtual environment is is a completely
self-contained environment that's
specific to that project so we're going
to set one of those up here now to get
started building our virtual environment
we need a project folder to work work
out of so I'm just going to create a new
folder on my desktop here I'm going to
call it Richard
project now in vs code we're going to go
ahead and open that so you're going to
go up here to file open
folder let's find that project folder we
created and now that's our working
project folder in vs code next we're
going to go up here to our terminal
we're going to open up a new terminal
and you're going to run the command
python
DM
VV and now this is where you give it a
name I'm just going to call it Richard
en
EnV and now we have this Richard EnV
virtual environment inside of our
project folder now now let's create a
new
script create a new file
this is going to be another simple hello
world script I'm going to save it as
Richard
script again just a simple hello world
print
statement before anything though just to
get inside this virtual environment you
want to go over and kill that terminal
that we were working out of and let's go
ahead and run this script
here you'll notice down here this activ
v. pss1 Powershell script was
run so if we hadn't done that step
earlier with Powershell this part would
probably fail for you but notice we're
working out of Richard EnV now our
virtual environment is all set up so now
if you want to go ahead and download
packages in here you can do that this is
an entirely self-contained thing that's
not going to interfere with other
projects that you work on so that
concludes this tutorial on setting up a
python environment now again I want to
stress there's no one siiz fits all
solution to this it all depends on your
experience and comfort level and just
how you prefer to work with python so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
hit the like button and leave me a
comment down below and just let me know
what your favorite uh text editor and
environment for python is then I'll see
you all in the notso distant future
until then Richard data